Si quieren aprender a tocar la langosta tenemos algunas aquí.
Y no es una broma, realmente las tenemos.
Así que vengan después y les mostraré cómo tocar la langosta.
En realidad, comencé trabajando con lo que se llama camarón mantis
hace unos años porque producen sonido.
Esta es una grabación que hice de un camarón mantis
que se encuentra en la costa de California.
Y si bien es un sonido absolutamente fascinante
realmente es un proyecto muy difícil.
Y mientras luchaba por dar con la forma de producción de sonido del
camarón mantis o los estomatópodos comencé a pensar en sus apéndices.
Y los camarones mantis se llaman así en honor a las mantis religiosas
que también tienen un veloz apéndice alimentario. Comencé a pensar
bien, quizá sea interesante, al escuchar sus sonidos,
saber cómo es que estos animales generan movimientos tan veloces.
Y por eso hoy hablaré de los golpes extremos del estomatópodo
trabajo que hicimos junto a Wyatt Korff y Roy Caldwell.
Los camarones mantis vienen en dos variedades:
están los arponeadores y los trituradores.
Y este es un camarón mantis arponeador, o estomatópodo.
Vive en la arena y atrapa cosas que pasan por encima.
Así un golpe rápido como ese. Y, un poco más lento,
este es el camarón mantis -- la misma especie --
grabado a 1.000 cuadros por segundo
reproducido a 15 cuadros por segundo.
Puede verse una extensión de las garras realmente espectacular
explotando hacia arriba para atrapar
un trozo muerto de camarón que le ofrecí.
El otro tipo de camarón mantis es el estomatópodo triturador
y estos tipos abren caracoles como medio de vida.
Así este sujeto le da al caracol un castañazo
(Risas)
Lo voy a pasar una vez más.
Se contonea, da un tirón con el hocico y tritura.
Y luego de eso el caracol ya está abierto y es una buena cena.
Así el apéndice predatorio puede apuñalar con una punta al final
o puede despedazar con el talón.
Y hoy hablaré del golpe de despedazamiento.
Y entonces la primera pregunta que me surgió
bien, ¿cuán rápido se mueve esta garra?
Porque se mueve bastante rápido en ese video.
E inmediatamente encontré un problema.
Ningún sistema de video de alta velocidad del departamento de biología
de Berkeley era suficientemente veloz para capturar este movimiento.
Simplemente no podíamos capturarlo en video.
Esto me desconcertó durante mucho tiempo.
Y luego vino un equipo de la BBC al departamento de biología
en busca de alguna historia en nuevas tecnologías de biología.
Y entonces hicimos un acuerdo.
Les dije: "Bien, muchachos, si alquilan el sistema de video de alta velocidad
que pueda capturar estos movimientos
pueden filmarnos recolectando los datos".
Y créase o no, lo hicieron.
Fue así que accedimos al sistema de video. Tecnología de punta --
había salido hacía cerca de un año --
que permite filmar a velocidades altísimas con poca luz.
Y poca luz es algo crítico al filmar animales
porque si es muy alta quedan fritos.
Así, esto es un camarón mantis. Esos son los ojos
hay un apéndice predador y el talón.
Esa cosa va a contonearse y pegarle al caracol.
El caracol está sujeto a un palo
por eso es más fácil montar el golpe. Y -- sí
(Risas)
Espero que no haya aquí activistas por los derechos del caracol.
Esto fue filmado a 5.000 cuadros por segundo
y lo estoy reproduciendo a 15. Entonces se ralentizó 333 veces.
Y como notarán todavía es bastante rápido
ralentizado 333 veces. Es un movimiento increíblemente potente.
Se extiende toda la garra. El cuerpo se flexiona hacia atrás
un movimiento espectacular.
Lo que hicimos fue mirar estos videos
y medimos la velocidad del movimiento de la garra
para regresar a la pregunta original.
Y hallamos la primer sorpresa.
Lo que calculamos era que las garras se movían
a la velocidad pico desde 10 metros por segundo
hasta 23 metros por segundo.
Y para los que prefieren kilómetros por hora
es más de 70 km por hora en agua. Y eso es muy rápido.
De hecho, es tan rápido que podíamos agregar un nuevo punto
al extremo del espectro del movimiento animal.
Y el camarón mantis tiene, oficialmente, el golpe más veloz registrado
del reino animal. Nuestra primera sorpresa.
(Aplausos)
Eso fue muy cool e inesperado.
Se preguntarán, bien, ¿cómo lo hacen?
Y en realidad este trabajo es de los '60s,
de un biólogo famoso llamado Malcolm Burrows.
Y lo que muestra del camarón mantis es que usan
lo que se llama mecanismo de captura, o de clic.
Y básicamente consta de un gran músculo
que se contrae en bastante tiempo
y de un pestillo que inmoviliza todo.
Entonces se contrae el músculo y no pasa nada.
Y una vez que el músculo se contrae por completo, todo acumulado
el pestillo va hacia arriba, y se produce el movimiento.
Eso es básicamente lo que se llama un sistema de amplificación de potencia.
El músculo se contrae en un tiempo largo
y la garra vuela en un tiempo muy corto.
Y pensé que esto era el fin de la historia.
Así es como el camarón mantis da estos golpes tan rápidos.
Pero después hice un viaje al Museo Nacional de Historia Natural.
Y si alguno tiene la oportunidad alguna vez
la trastienda del Museo Nacional de Historia Natural
es de las mejores colecciones mundiales de camarones mantis preservados.
(Risas)
esto es algo serio para mí.
Esto -- lo que veo en cada garra de camarón mantis
sea un arponeador o un triturador
es una hermosa estructura de montura
justo en la superficie superior de la garra. Pueden verla aquí.
Se ve como una montura puesta en un caballo.
Es una estructura muy bella.
Está rodeada de áreas membranosas. Y esas áreas membranosas
me sugieren que quizá sea una especie de estructura dinámicamente flexible.
Y esto me hizo pensar bastante.
E hicimos una serie de cálculos, y lo que llegamos a mostrar
es que estos camarones mantis tienen que tener un resorte.
Tiene que haber una especie de mecanismo de carga de resorte
para generar la cantidad de fuerza que observamos
y la velocidad que observamos y la salida del sistema.
Entonces pensamos, bien, esto debe ser un resorte
la montura podría muy bien ser un resorte.
Y volvimos a los videos de alta velocidad de nuevo
y pudimos ver la montura comprimirse y extenderse.
Lo repetiré una vez más.
Y si miran el video
es bastante difícil verlo -- está resaltado en amarillo.
La montura está resaltada en amarillo. Pueden verla
extenderse en el curso del golpe, hiperextendiéndose en realidad.
Así, teníamos evidencia muy sólida que mostraba
que esa estructura de montura en realidad se comprime y extiende
y actúa, de hecho, como un resorte.
La estructura de montura se conoce también como superficie paraboloide hiperbólica
o superficie anticlástica.
Y esto es muy bien sabido por ingenieros y arquitectos
porque es una superficie muy fuerte en compresión.
Tiene curvas en dos direcciones
una curva hacia arriba y la otra opuesta transversal hacia abajo
así toda perturbación dispersa las fuerzas
sobre la superficie de este tipo de forma.
Entonces es muy conocida por los ingenieros y no así por los biólogos.
Es conocida también por mucha gente que hace joyería
porque requiere muy poco material
para construir este tipo de superficies y es muy fuerte.
Así, si uno va a construir una estructura delgada de oro
es muy bueno hacerla en una forma que sea fuerte.
Ahora, es conocida también por arquitectos. Uno de los arquitectos más famosos
es Eduardo Catalano, quien popularizó esta estructura.
Y este es un techo en forma de montura que él construyó
de 26 metros y medio de envergadura.
Tiene más de 6 centímetros de ancho y se apoya en dos puntos.
Y una de las razones por las que diseñó techos de esta manera es debido a que
encontró fascinante que se pueda construir una estructura tan fuerte
con tan pocos materiales y que se pueda apoyar en tan pocos puntos.
Y todos estos principios son los mismos que se aplican
al resorte de montura de los estomatópodos.
En sistemas biológicos es importante no tener la parafernalia
de material extra para construirlo.
Así, hay paralelos muy interesantes entre los mundos de la
biología y la ingeniería. Y lo interesante resulta ser que
la montura del estomatópodo resulta ser el primer resorte
biológico paraboloide hiperbólico descripto.
Es un poco largo, pero como que es interesante.
Así la siguiente y última pregunta fue, bien, ¿cuánta fuerza
produce el camarón mantis si puede abrir caracoles?
Y así yo conecté lo que se llama celdas de carga.
Una celda de carga mide fuerzas y esta es en realidad
una celda de carga piezoelectrónica que tiene un pequeño cristal.
Y cuando se presiona este cristal cambian las propiedades eléctricas
en proporción a la fuerza que recibe.
Así, estos animales son maravillosamente agresivos
y tienen hambre todo el tiempo. Entonces todo lo que tuve que hacer
fue poner pasta de camarón al frente de la celda de carga
y entonces ellos le pegaban.
Esto es un video normal del animal
pegándole a esta celda de carga.
Y pudimos medir algunas fuerzas.
De nuevo, nos sorprendimos.
Yo compré una celda de carga de 45 kg pensando
que ningún animal de ese tamaño podría producir más de 45 kg.
¿Y saben qué? Inmediatamente sobrepasaron la celda de carga.
Estos son en verdad datos viejos
en los que encontramos los animales más pequeños del laboratorio
y pudimos medir fuerzas de bastante más que 45 kg
generadas por una animal de cerca de este tamaño.
Y realmente la semana pasada conseguí una celda de carga de 136 kg
en funcionamiento y cronometré a estos animales generando
más de 90 kg de fuerza.
Nuevamente, pensé que esto sería un récord mundial.
Tengo que documentarme un poco más
pero pienso que esta será la cantidad más grande de fuerza producida
por un animal por unidad de masa corporal. Así, fuerzas increíbles.
De nuevo, esto nos retrotrae a la importancia de ese resorte
que almacena y libera tanta energía en este sistema.
Pero ese no fue el fin de la historia.
ahora, las cosas -- esto suena muy fácil, pero lleva mucho trabajo conseguirlo.
Obtuve todas estas mediciones de fuerza
y luego fui a ver la salida de fuerzas del sistema.
Esto es muy simple -- el tiempo está en el eje X
y la fuerza está en el eje Y. Pueden verse dos picos.
Y eso fue lo que me dejó intrigada.
El primer pico, obviamente, es la garra golpeando la celda de carga.
Pero hay un segundo gran pico medio milisegundo después
y yo no sabía qué era.
Entonces uno esperaría un segundo pico por otras razones
pero no medio milisegundo después.
Otra vez, volviendo a esos videos de alta velocidad
hay una pista bastante buena de lo que puede estar sucediendo.
Aquí hay esa misma orientación que vimos antes.
Está el apéndice predatorio -- está el talón
y va a menearse e impactar la celda de carga.
Y lo que quiero que hagan en esta toma es que miren esto
en la superficie de la celda de carga, mientras pasa la garra.
Y espero que lo que puedan ver sea en verdad un destello de luz.
Audiencia: ¡Guau!
Sheila Patek: Y si tomamos ese cuadro, lo que vemos allí
al final de la flecha amarilla es una burbuja de vapor.
Eso es la cavitación.
La cavitación es un fenómeno extremadamente potente de la dinámica de fluidos
que ocurre cuando uno tiene áreas de agua
que se mueven a velocidades muy diferentes.
Cuando esto sucede, puede provocar áreas de muy baja presión
que da como resutado, literalmente, la evaporación de agua.
Y cuando estalla la burbuja de vapor emite sonido, luz y calor;
es un proceso muy destructivo.
Y aquí en el estomatópodo. Nuevamente, es una situación en que
los ingenieros están muy familiarizados con este fenómeno
porque destruye las hélices de los barcos.
La gente hace años que viene luchando tratando de diseñar
una hélice que gire muy rápido pero no cavite
porque, literalmente, desgaste el metal y hace hoyos en las hélices
como muestran estas imágenes.
Entonces esta es una fuerza potente de los sistemas de fluidos y para llevarlo un poco más lejos
les voy a mostrar el camarón mantis acercarse al caracol.
Esta fue fomada a 20.000 cuadros por segundo y tengo que dar
crédito al camarógrafo de la BBC, Tim Green, por lograr esta toma
porque yo no hubiera podido hacerlo ni en un millón de años.
Una de las ventajas de trabajar con camarógrafos profesionales.
Pueden verlo llegar y un destello de luz increíble
y toda esta cavitación esparcida por la superficie del caracol.
Así, realmente, una imagen asombrosa
ralentizada al extremo, a velocidades extremadamente bajas.
De nuevo, podemos verla de manera ligeramente diferente allí
formando la burbuja y explotando entre esas dos superficies.
De hecho, podrían haber visto alguna cavitación en el borde de la garra.
Así, para resolver el dilema de los dos picos de fuerza:
lo que pensé que estaba sucediendo fue que el primer impacto es
la garra golpeando la celda de carga y el segundo es
la explosión de la burbuja de cavitación.
Y estos animales pueden muy bien estar haciendo uso de
no sólo la fuerza y energía almacenada con ese resorte especializado
sino los extremos de la dinámica de fluidos. Y pueden en realidad estar
usando la dinámica de fluidos como segunda fuerza para romper el caracol.
Una suerte de latigazo doble, por así decirlo, de estos animales.
Entonces una pregunta que suelen hacerme al final de estas charlas
que imagino contestarla ahora -- es, bien, ¿qué pasa con el animal?
Porque, obviamente, si parte caracoles,
la pobre garra debe desintegrarse. Y, de hecho, lo hace.
Esa es la parte del talón que impacta en ambas imágenes
y queda desgastado. De hecho, los he visto desgastar
su talón hasta quedar en carne viva.
Pero una ventaja de ser artrópodo
es que cambian la piel. Y cada tres meses aproximadamente
estos animales cambian la piel y construyen una nueva garra sin problema.
Una solución muy, muy, práctica para ese problema particular.
Me gustaría termianr con una nota extravagante.
(Risas)
Quizá todo esto sea extravagante para gente como Uds., no lo sé.
Las monturas -- ese resorte de montura --
es bien conocido por biólogos desde hace mucho tiempo
no como resorte pero sí como señal visual.
Y hay un punto espectacularmente coloreado
en el centro de las monturas de muchas especies de estomatópodos.
Y eso es muy interesante, encontrar orígenes evolutivos
de señales visuales en lo que son, en todas las especies, sus resortes.
Y pienso que una explicación de esto podría ser
volviendo al fenómeno de cambio de piel.
Estos animales entran en un período de cambio de piel en que
no golpean -- sus cuerpos quedan muy blandos.
Y, literalmente, no pueden golpear o se autodestruirían.
Esto es real. Y lo que hacen es, hasta que ese período
en que no pueden golpear, se vuelven repugnantes y espantosos
y le pegan a todo lo que ven sin importar quién o qué sea.
Luego entran en ese punto del tiempo en que no pueden golpear más
sólo señalan. Mueven sus piernas.
Es uno de los ejemplos típicos en comportamiento animal de fingir.
Es un hecho muy conocido de estos animales
que en realidad fingen. No pueden golpear realmente, pero fingen hacerlo.
Y me tiene intrigada si esos puntos coloreados
del centro de la montura llevan algún tipo de información
sobre su habilidad para golpear o de su fuerza de golpe
y algo sobre el período del ciclo de cambio de piel.
Es un hecho extraño e interesante encontrar una estructura visual
en medio de la montura de su resorte.
Para terminar quiero agradecer a mis dos colaboradores
Wyatt Korff y Roy Caldwell, que trabajaron conmigo codo a codo.
Y también al Instituto Miller de Investigación Básica en Ciencia
que me financió durante tres años para hacer ciencia todo el tiempo
y por eso estoy muy agradecida. Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)